france 3 vous fait vivre à cette soirée
à suspense en bourgogne et franche comté
pour ce deuxième tour des élections
régionales nous vous donnerons les
derniers chiffres disponibles mais
d'abord voyons qui nous a rejoint pour
commenter ces chiffres
au doré avec nous sur le plateau michel
neugnot du parti socialiste tête de
liste pour la côte-d'or vous êtes aussi
le directeur de campagne de mariée du
fait à vos côtés gilles platret lé maire
de chalon sur saône la liste lr udi pour
justement la saône et loire est à vos
côtés lilian noirot et front national
chef de file de la somme et noir bonjour
bonsoir messieurs merci d'être avec nous
on va redonner tout de suite
arnaud les estimations et on réserve
évidemment la deuxième et la troisième
fois c'est très serré ce mois-là
estimation ipsos oprah steria pour
france télévisions vous allez voir les
derniers chiffres disponibles
il donne donc marie guite dufay la liste
ps prg en tête avec 34% des voix
derrière lui dis avec les républicains
françois sauvadet 33,5 et le front
national mené par sophie montel à 32,5
les derniers chiffres disponibles mais
les derniers bulletins un dernier vote
sont ceux des grandes villes
et il y aurait donc un rapprochement
peut-être d'espoir entre le front
national et l'air udi estimations
toujours a pas de résultats définitifs
restez avec nous nous affinons ses
estimations tout au long de cette soirée
et marie-guite dufay nous attend
préfecture de dijon en direct pour sa
première réaction victoire a priori donc
de votre liste marie guite dufay
j'imagine une satisfaction ce soir et
peut-être aussi un soulagement oui tout
à fait un soulagement cette semaine a
été une semaine sous très grande
pression l'idée que le front national
puisse être à la tête de notre région
était une idée qu'il fallait absolument
combattre nous avons mis toutes nos
forces nous avons fait appel à tous les
démocrates
donc je suis soulagée j'ai conscience
que beaucoup m'ont fait confiance et
qu'il faudra que je sois digne de cette
confiance
nous avons rassemblé les forces de
gauche mais j'ai bien le sentiment que
cette gauche rassemblée pour ce deuxième
tour est bien doit énormément travaillé
pour retrouve
et ses valeurs et son socle commun de
valeurs j'en ai totalement conscience
gsk est ce que cette victoire
marie-guite dufay vous donne plus
d'engagement que si vous aviez gagné
dans un autre contexte
peut-être peut-être parce que je sens qu
effectivement ce qui se passe c'est la
cassure complète de dans notre pays où
il y a ceux qui ont confiance dans la
chose publique et ceux qui n'ont pas
confiance et ceux qui n'ont pas
confiance sont très nombreux et il faut
absolument travailler à retrouver cette
confiance et ça passe par un
rassemblement très très important il
faut pouvoir avoir des engagements forts
sur le sujet numéro un qui est le sujet
du chômage bien voir que dans une région
nous n'avons pas toutes les cartes en
main mais que nous en avons une qui est
essentiel et qui est notre compétence en
matière de formation il nous faut
absolument inventé ce qui s'appelle une
sécurité professionnelle à l'aube du 21e
siècle c'est le devoir de la gauche que
de créer cette sécurité professionnelle
donc nous devons prendre cet engagement
et nous devons le tenir tenir ses
engagements dire ce que l'on fait c'est
que ce que tous les français tous les
électeurs attendent
marie-guite dufay a priori votre
majorité sera tenu cinquante et un 51
sièges ou 50 52 on sait pas est-ce que
du coup vous vous comptez travailler de
manière ouverte en collaboration avec
votre opposition se comptent travailler
dans le dialogue le plus ouvert vous
savez dans une assemblée le dialogue
entre l'opposition et la majorité il est
naturel et il est important d'avoir une
opposition qui soit forte qui soit
critiqué la critique est toujours
constructives et il me semble que dans
l'exercice de mes responsabilités
précédentes en franche comté
je n'ai pas mépriser l'opposition bien
au contraire merci mr guide du flux en
direct de la préfecture de côte-d'or
pour cette première réelle sont avant
tendu sophie montel et marie guite dufay
nous attendons dans les prochaines
minutes une réaction de
françois sauvadet pour elle est rude et
y est pour ce camp justement l érudit
nous partons pour paris en direct au
téléphone avec nous à alain joyandet
bonsoir alain joyandet où vous étiez le
numéro un en haute saône donc pour cette
liste elle est rude et vous êtes proche
de nicolas sarkozy proche
évidemment de l'état-major des
républicains vous dites quoi ce soir
votre chef de parti qu'il s'est trompé
pour cette campagne des régionales en
bourgogne franche comté
pas du tout parce que je pense que
l'accord national qui a été passée nous
permet d'obtenir ce soir sur le plan
national
un résultat qui est tout à fait
satisfaisant même si nous n'avons pas
encore les résultats pour plusieurs
régions
donc il fallait faire l'union l'union a
été fait on était dans un accord
national
je ne pense pas que nous avions la
possibilité de ne pas nous y lire dans
un moment où les français souffrent où
la france est en grande difficulté donc
sur le plan des décisions qui ont été
prises par nicolas sarkozy et je pense
qu'il n'y a rien à changer
on a quand même connu des oppositions
nationale plus forte on a vu quand
nicolas sarkozy était président la
gauche avait raflé toutes les régions
sauf l'alsace en métropole
là on voit que les gars ne sont pas les
mêmes pour la droite contre françois
hollande et président de la république
oui mais vous noterez aussi quand
nicolas sarkozy président de la
république le front national n'est pas
au score où il est aujourd'hui
le parti socialiste a toujours été un
moteur pour le front national
on le sait à chaque fois que je vois que
le parti socialiste est au pouvoir il
fait monter le front national un peu les
pyromanes font monter le front national
et puis quand il est inquiétant ce
moment là on lance un appel aux
démocrates mais rappelez-vous ça a été
comme ça sous mitterrand c'était comme
ça sous jospin c'est comme ça sourit
hollande
et quand nicolas sarkozy était président
de la république parce qu'on avait une
vraie politique sur les valeurs et bien
les électeurs n'allez pas au front
national il restait dans la droite
républicaine
ça ne veut pas dire que la droite
républicaine est trop faible ça veut pas
dire qu'elle est trop fait ça veut
surtout dire que à un moment où on nous
disait qu'on n'en faisait pas beaucoup
non plus au nom faisait tron
on nous disait qu'on en faisait trop et
à l'intérieur de la droite nous disait
justement on nous on allait peut-être un
peu trop loin vers la droite je pense
qu'aujourd'hui la france est très à
droite
voilà très à droite pensent qu'une
demande de réforme
de retour aux valeurs valeur travail
vraiment lutter contre le chômage la
sécurité des français
tous ces sujets
que que nicolas sarkozy dit et redit
depuis des mois et des années on revient
que le vôtre nationale je parle du vote
national aujourd'hui je pense que il y
aura des débats dans les jours qui
viennent
évidemment sur la ligne politique
justement la jeunesse que vous
considérez qu'il ya un problème de ligne
aujourd'hui chez les républicains
je crois que si on disait pas aussi ce
soir on ne reconnaissait pas qu'il y
avait un problème de ligne chez les
républicains
pour le coup je pense qu'on ne verrait
pas très clair moi pour moi la ligne est
claire mais je pense qu'il n'est pas
clair pour tout le monde
or la lignée l'éclair la ligne c'est un
c 'est un parti chez les républicains
qui doivent fait à droite dans la droite
républicaine
mais à droite sans faillir sur les sur
les grandes valeurs sur la sécurité des
français sur leurs offres sur
l'immigration sur la priorité à donner
au chômage la priorité aussi un plan
marshall pour la ruralité depuis le
temps qu'on le demande il faudra un
petit peu de temps pour regarder tout
simple plus dans le détail mais moi en
tout cas évidemment il ya plusieurs
lignes république
en ce qui me concerne je pense que le
résultat des élections
au premier tour dimanche dernier avec ce
qui s'est passé donc aussi bien en rhône
alpes que dans les pays de la loire
je pense que on est deux on avait des
résultats qui est très clair qu'ils
étaient très claires et qui donnait une
orientation sur ce qu'attendent les
français et donc pour le coup
aujourd'hui le deuxième tour conforte
complètement ça et je pense qu'on a bien
fait de faire de faire l'union pour
qu'aujourd'hui je rappelle quand même le
résultat national ce soir c'est quand
même les républicains merci merci
beaucoup on rappelle que vous étiez donc
en duplex par téléphone depuis le doubs
à présent jean louis fousseret nous
attend à besançon au kursaal jean louis
fousseret le maire socialiste de
besançon le département du doubs où
marie guite dufay arrive en tête un
résultat définitif avec un peu plus de
37% des voix derrière le fn et la liste
de françois sauvadet avec seulement 16
voix d'écart à peu près 31 3%
satisfaction pour vous jean louis
fousseret marie-guite dufay fait plus
qu'au niveau de la bourgogne franche
comté dans votre département
oui bien sûr c'est un très bon score
pour marié teuw dans le département du
doubs et aussi à besançon effet presque
53 % c'est aussi la reconnaissance de
ses qualités de son travail et puis sur
heureux de voir que besançon et dijon
les grandes villes restent fortement
ancrés à gauche c'est important pour
demain pour pour l'avenir fait 52,4 % à
dans votre vote revivre tout à l'heure
françois rebsamen qui était sur notre
plateau par led parlais je vais le
résumé en gros des lecteurs des villes
et des lecteurs deschamps est ce que
vous faites un peu la même analyse et
qu'aujourd'hui il ya vraiment deux
électorats en bourgogne franche comté
je suis je sais que ce qu'ils disent
qu'il faut surtout oui bien sûr ce ne
sont pas les même électorat bien sûr
mais je compte sur tout ce qu'il faut
faire dans cette nouvelle grande région
c'est que chacune et chacun puisse
travailler ensemble les villes et comme
vous dites
les chiens pub mais je compte ce qui est
encore plus important à mon sens c'est
qu'il faut retenir les leçons de cette
élection
il ne faut pas passer ce moment de joie
aujourd'hui tombé dans l'oubli tomber
dans le déni il suffit pas de dire qu'on
a entendu l'appel
il va falloir y répondre avec des
propositions concrètes car c'est cela
qu'on attend de nous on peut pas
continuer à se faire peur comme ça à
chaque chaque soir de l'ex ionisants on
vous entendu maintenant il faut il faut
agir pour que nous ayons les idées
claires des lignes politiques claires il
faut aussi que la gauche recompose on
voit bien d'ailleurs que ceux qui à ceux
qui ont gagné ici ce sont des forces de
gauche unie seul effectivement nous nous
aurions perdu
alors quand j'attends de lui en demander
une orientation à gauche de la politique
gouvernementale par exemple monsieur
frustré ce soir
je demande que l'on entende
effectivement ce que disent les femmes
et les hommes de ce pays
c'est je pense la petite gouvernement
elle est bonne vous savez que je que je
la soutiens simplement il faut peut-être
aller plus loin dans certaines
directions et puis montré que
effectivement nous avons les moyens et
la volonté de combattre encore plus ce
cancer qu'est le chômage et je fais pour
sa confiance à la fois marie-guite dufay
au niveau régional et la fois au premier
ministre au président de la république
c'est clair si on les fout sera directe
de besançon des résultats définitifs
nous arrive pour les départements juste
un petit tour par les réseaux sociaux
peut être elle avec des tweets qui
arrive en ce moment alors très peu
tweets des personnalités politiques
alors je vous propose quelques
instantanés tout de même cette soirée
grise mine comme nous le dit france bleu
auxerre pour les militants de françois
sauvadet à dijon théo souvent notre
confrère qui est au qg d'alain de
françois sauvadet je vais y arriver
une seat alain suguenot qui parle de
défaites quand on voit les résultats
dans les villes il ya des questions à se
poser
laurent grandguillaume louis se
contentent de saluer la victoire de la
république
il appelle maintenant à une mobilisation
il faut remettre l'humain au coeur des
choix et cette dernière réaction des mjs
du doubs nous exprimons ce soir notre
soulagement après la victoire de
marie-guite dufay des estimations des
résultats définitifs pour les
départements sept des huit départements
art événement que la côte d'or nous
devons faire un tour de raison justement
de ces départements dont nous avons les
résultats définitifs
au dos on commence avec la franche-comté
puisqu'on avait quatre départements de
ou dans lequel le front national avait
requis devant tête c'est le territoire
de belfort d'abord la liste de sophie
montel décroche 35,3 % des suffrages
devant la liste du parti socialiste 34
4% enfin elle est rude et y 30,3 %
l'autre département qui place le front
national en tête c'est la haute saône la
haute saône à 38,54 % pour la liste de
son fils mentale 33,14 pour la liste de
marie guite dufay 28 33 pour lr udi le
jura et le doubs place la liste parti
socialiste demande du fait en tête
d'ange rats 36,11 % des suffrages vont
liste de marie-guite dufay 32 89 pour
françois sauvadet 31% pour sophie montel
et donc j'en termine avec le doubs à 37
42 % pour la liste socialiste 31-29 pour
la liste front national
enfin 31 28 pour la liste lr unis on
passe à bombay la bourgogne avec et
l'yonne la nièvre et la saône-et-loire
l'yonne d'abord place sophie montel et
le front national en tête avec un peu
plus de 37% des suffrages au deuxième
tour devant françois sauvadet avec 32,7
et la liste de marie guite dufay arrive
troisième avec 29,6 pour cent des
suffrages dans la nièvre à présent la
liste de marie-guite dufay ps prg arrive
en tête avec un peu plus de 39% des voix
devant la liste front national 33,8 et
la liste allait rudy 26,8 terminons par
le département de la saône-et-loire avec
marie-guite dufay en tête avec près de
35% des suffrages ce soir devant
françois sauvadet 34,4 et le front
national de sophie montel à 37% nous
terminons par ce département puisque
deux représentants de saône et loire
sont avec nous et lilian noirot et
gilles platret gilles platret françois
sauvadet arrive seulement deuxième dans
votre département de saône et loire
ainsi que sur la ville de chalon sur
saône que vous avez ravi à la gauche
l'an dernier
c'est une déception c'est certain il ya
une belle mobilisation de l'électorat de
gauche je note toutefois que le total
gauche par rapport au total droite s'est
réduit sur l'écart que nous avions vécu
à l'issue du premier tour s'est réduit
au deuxième mais ils sont néanmoins
devant ce que ce qui moi me fait plaisir
c'est que nous comptons non le front
national à un niveau qui est certes déjà
trop élevé à chalon 22% mais en tout cas
qui est bien inférieur à celui qu'on
connaît par ailleurs c'est une vraie
déception
on attend le résultat de côte-d'or moi
je vais simplement dire une chose c'est
que le résultat condor sera très bon
pour françois sauvadet et que quand les
gens voient un élu sur le terrain
certainement il est très bon et
conseille les présidents de leurs
départements de côte-d'or
quant à les électeurs voient les
résultats d'une politique menée sur le
terrain comme celle que mène françois
sauvadet
ils votent pour lui donc on voit bien
que cette élection ne s'est pas portée
sur des enjeux projet mais qu'elle a été
court circuiter polluer disons comme on
veut par d'autres enjeux qui n'ont pas
été des enjeux locaux
cette année entamée c'est ainsi vous
n'êtes pas très gentil pour vous même
parce que dans votre ville vous
françois sauvadet arrivent deuxièmes et
derrière marie-guite dufay politique il
pourrait le dire à d'autres occasions
j'ai été élu au premier tour il ya 18
mois donc je pense que s'il fallait
refaire aujourd'hui les élections
municipales nous les gagnerions encore
simplement je vois aujourd'hui à chalon
comme dans d'autres secteurs de notre
notre région que les enjeux locaux ou
régionaux qui était ce que nous avions
mis au coeur de notre projet on était la
seule liste à avoir un vrai projet pour
pour cette nouvelle grande région n'ont
pas été au coeur des discussions
et c'est pas là dessus que les électeurs
se sont prononcés donc on en prend acte
on est aujourd'hui sur trois disent
qu'ils sont pratiquement à égalité
je pense que du côté socialiste il ne
faut surtout pas faire de triomphalisme
quand on gagne à moins d'un point dans
une triangulaire
ça veut dire que vous avez deux tiers
des électeurs qui ne veulent pas de vous
aujourd'hui les bourguignons et à partir
demain matin se retrouve avec la même
majorité que celle qui a gouverné la
bourgogne et la franche comté
je pense très sincèrement que ça n'est
pas son co fonde mail il souhaitait mais
c'est pourtant ce qu'ils vont avoir
désormais monsieur platret vu les
résultats qui nous arrive
l'impression du premier tour se confirme
françois sauvadet n'a pas adhéré en est
va perdre ce soir à cause de la franche
comté
il fait beaucoup moins franche comté
qu'en bourgogne y at il un problème avec
la droite franc comtoise je sais pas si
un problème est que la fin de contrat je
pense qu'il ya eu un problème avec avec
l'impression que les comptoirs ont eu à
un moment donné qu'un candidats
bourguignons met la main sur l'ensemble
du territoire
on peut pas excepté dans le vote comtois
ce sentiment qui avait et on l'a senti
d'ailleurs sur le terrain que la peur
d'une bourgogne omnipotente qui
prendraient toutes les manettes y
compris pour le territoire comtois se
fasse jour c'est exactement ce qui s'est
passé je pense que ça a pesé beaucoup
dans le vote qui n'a pas été vers
françois sauvadet 16h15 racinaire
d'ailleurs du coup un meilleur candidat
mais je ne sais pas écoutez moi j'étais
j'avais dit au départ que je soutenais
alain joyandet mais nous sommes ralliés
d'ailleurs alain l'a très bien dit on
s'est rallié au nom de l'unité parce que
cette unité entre les républicains lui
dit elle
nécessaire donc je vais vous dire qu'il
n'a pas manqué une voix des républicains
pour le candidat françois sauvadet qui a
fait une magnifique campagne une
campagne bugnon donc on ne regrette pas
du tout cela mais simplement je pense
qu'il va falloir travailler pour que
cette grande région qui nous a été
imposée qui a qui n'a pas été voté par
nos élus au parlement mais qui est
aujourd'hui une réalité se fasse sans
qu'une partie du territoire et le
sentiment qu'elle est spoliée par l'eau
je pense que cette peur là à jouer
contre françois sauvadet
c'est regrettable parce que c'était dans
la logique qui étaient là mychèle daniau
les bourguignons eux n'ont pas eu peur
visiblement de voter pour une franc
comtoise pour les électeurs de gauche
bourguignon mais non parce que nous
portons la bourgogne franche-comté
marie-guite dufay françois patriat ont
été très allants sur cette idée de
bourgogne franche comté et sur la loi
nome qui permet de donner des
compétences plus clair à chacun des
niveaux de collectivités
on n'a pas essayé d'opposer la bourgogne
franche comté
quel était notre slogan en effet pour
l'iran semble donc dès le départ on a
pas additionner la bourgogne franche
comté on essaie de monter un projet
politique pour cette nouvelle grande
région et c'est cela qui a porté et
croyez bien que dans nos préoccupations
de deux présentes dans cette campagne
chacun a apporté sa part et on n'a pas
essayé au samedi dans là l'avenir
les avenirs c'est une grande région avec
de nouvelles compétences s'organiser on
n'a pas fait une campagne qui s'appuyait
sur le passé une campagne de projection
de l'avenir répondant à un certain
nombre de préoccupations dans un temps
où on sait que la politique et la parole
politique est difficile à pencher sur
les résultats comme je disais j4 est
finalement c'est un tiers un tiers un
tiers en gros avec effectivement un
petit peu plus pour marie-guite dufay
qui aura donc la majorité mode de
scrutin le cela est-ce que du coup elle
a une réelle
légitimité à diriger cette région je
suis très étonné de votre question moi
même je vais vous dire j'ai gagné une
municipale en triangulaire avec une voix
d'avancé
personne n'a contesté cette légitimité
c'est une obligation elle reconnaissait
le salut ami à quelques minutes mais je
répondrai pas la question légitimité
par contre quelle va être notre attitude
il ya une reconnaissance vis-à-vis de
toutes les forces politiques qui
présente ou non sur nos listes nous ont
aidés dans ce deuxième tour en écho le
parti communiste
et puis un certain nombre parce que nous
ne sommes pas sourds au message une lame
reçu le lion vote pour vous mais c'est
pas blanc seing au parti socialiste on a
deux là et c'est cela qu'il faut
intégrer
je pense que on est dans un tripartisme
quasiment à un tiers un tiers un tiers
actuellement il faut l'entendre compter
c'est sûr que la gestion de la région
devraient le prendre en compte ce que je
remarque c'est quand même notre grande
peur aux uns et aux autres c'est de voir
cette région piloté par le front
national
et moi je me réjouis que le front
national arrive en troisième position et
que les deux forces
or l'entente de droite et de gauche
soient devant alors je ne sais pas pour
leurs frais une tradition que je sens
que j'ai beaucoup à vous lui tendez la
main ou presque vous la perche je ne
sais pas votre réaction ce soir le fn
était largement en tête avait beaucoup
d'avancé puis finalement vous avez tout
perdu vous êtes deuxièmes ou troisièmes
ça joue à rien a priori la totalité des
résultats est pas encore connue mais
quelle est votre réaction finalement le
fn n'a aucune région ce soir
écoutez je pense que tout d'abord c'est
une victoire puisque le front national
seul contre tous face l'union eut des
ump et face au parti socialiste et ses
pseudos alliés verts communistes celui
contre le front national
uniquement et nous on note quand même
une progression de notre score dans
l'intégralité des départements on voit
également que notre implantation locale
paye et surtout je note que front
national est seul contre tous alors que
l'ump lui dise
se rejoignent alors qu'on nous savons
pertinemment les est ce que c'est un
fait en grèce justement vous êtes seul
au contraire nous on n'est pas seul
puisque on a le peuple avec nous le
peuple bassa renvoi bah si parce que
justement quand vous regardez les
résultats
si le ps et l'ump leurs alliés seraient
tous seuls et joueraient le jeu on
serait vainqueur et là on voit que c'est
simplement des alliances de circonstance
et des alliances d'appareils uniquement
pour conserver la droitisation
départementale ps administrer les
régions avec des écologistes et des
communistes c'est pas des alliances de
circonstance pour ces jeunes
je vais regarder l'exemple de chalon sur
saône avec madame de chaume et cette
pseudo alliance lors des élections
municipales et qui étudient ou faisant
démissionner on sait pertinemment les
petits problèmes qui lie à dents dans
dans la municipalité menée par par
monsieur platret donc non écoutez moi je
pense que c'est une victoire pour le
front national ce soir et elle laisse
présager un très bon avenir notamment
pour les présidentielles puisque pour
les présidentielles on verra
pertinemment qui durera deux blocs le
bloc des mondialistes et bloquent des
patriotes que représente le front
national reste en première nous attend
depuis belfort il était la tête de liste
du modem pour cette élection régionales
en bourgogne franche comté
christophe grudler votre réaction au ce
soir à ce score est donc marie-guite
dufay en tête parce qu'on vous a peu
voire pas entendu du tout entre ces deux
tours on n'avait pas donné à titre
personnel en tout cas de consigne de
vote devant le modem m'écoutais je me
réjouis que le pire ait été évité ce
soir le pire c'est avec le front
national gagne donc je suis très content
de voir qu'il n'a pas gagné et donc je
félicite madame du fait qu'il en portait
effectivement ce soir c'est pas la
gauche et gagner soit je crois que c'est
important aussi de le dire ce que je
connais en franche-comté notamment des
élus des républicains des premiers tours
des des électeurs de républicains qui
ont voté pour madame buffet parce qu'il
voyait en elle une personne qui ait plus
de réserves de voix pour empêcher le
front national de gagner et ses
électeurs de droite
on va dire pour eux fn et ps s'est pas
exactement la même chose
donc il ya eu un travail qui a été fait
qui lui permet aujourd'hui de l'emporter
donc moi je pense que
elle peut pas continuer comme avant je
vais combattu la tête de la région
franche comté
elle peut pas dire c'est la gauche qui
poursuit son chemin habituel maintenant
elle doit se remettre en question avec
le séisme qui a eu lieu à semaine
dernière le se remettre en question
c'est à dire travailler avec les
républicains françois sauvadet au niveau
de la région
c'est également travaillé avec
l'ensemble des démocrates l'ensemble des
forces de cette région bourgogne franche
comté qui est en récession qui en
mauvaise situation et on doit s'occuper
des habitants pour les réconcilier avec
la politique et montrer qu'il ya
vraiment quelque chose à faire avec eux
donc moi j'appelle madame buffet à
ouvrir le plus largement possible
sa réflexion associer les acteurs
économiques notamment les acteurs à tous
niveaux pour qu'on puisse avoir une
région qui gagne demain christophe
grudler vous étiez à la tête de la seule
liste modem indépendante de france à
l'insu de votre plein gré je dirais
puisque vous souhaitiez fusionner dès le
premier tour avec la liste de françois
sauvadet comme dans le reste des régions
est ce qu'aujourd'hui le poids du modem
ne manquent pas pour que la droite
s'impose en bourgogne franche comté n'a
que très clairement il ya une erreur
stratégique majeure de la part de
françois sauvadet qui écoute et damien
meslot qui est venu le voir pour lui
dire qu'il fallait pas d'union avec le
centre et grâce à ça
ce soir il manque quelques points
françois sauvadet pour l'emporter je
pense que l'examen de conscience il doit
être fait en interne aux républicains à
lui les i
mais bon nous on a fait ce qu'il fallait
c'est christophe grudler en direct du
territoire de belfort nous partons pour
le qg de françois sauvadet justement en
parlions dans l'union de la droite
françois sauvadet s'exprime déclaration
direct sur france 3 de la tête de liste
elle est rude et nous l'écoutons
bon mais mes chers amis et premiers mots
sont d'abord pour vous remercier tous
les élus locaux les militants tous les
électeurs qui se sont prononcés pour
seul premier puis ce second tour avec
une forte mobilisation vous l'avait vu
enregistrer dans tous les départements
de cette belle région de bourgogne
franche comté
on a mené ensemble je le pense très
sincèrement une belle campagne une
campagne digne une campagne sobre une
campagne sur le projet et tout s'est
joué dans un mouchoir de poche
vous l'avez vu comme moi je pense que
françois rebsamen a pris avec cambadélis
et avec le porte parole du gouvernement
un vrai risque dans cette région de
bourgogne franche comté où chacun savait
que le front national restera très élevé
au soir du premier tour chacun savait il
a joué à la roulette russe
en tout cas trois régions je vous le dis
sont aujourd'hui avec un front national
qui est en tête trois départements de la
région
trois départements avec un front
national en tête et puis le résultat sur
lequel je ne reviens pas c'est une
situation évidemment extrêmement
complexe dans lequel va se retrouver
notre région avec finalement la
reconduction des mêmes ceux là même qui
ont conduit notre pays dans de grandes
difficultés
ceux là même qui ont conduit aussi notre
région dans de grandes difficultés
également en récession nous sommes des
rares jeux en récession j'ai eu
l'occasion de le répéter pendant toute
cette campagne est donc je ne vois pas
comment vont se réveiller tout ce qui
demain matin vous voir vous constatez on
prend les mêmes et on recommence alors
que premier tour les deux tiers de ceux
qui s'étaient exprimés avaient manifesté
l'envi clair d'un vrai changement est un
vrai changement pour la
un vrai changement en bourgogne franche
comté évidemment j'assume l'entière
responsabilité de cette campagne sont
perdus peu mais nous avons perdu ce que
je veux noter aussi j'en suis très
heureux c'est que contrairement à ce que
disait socialiste qui oppose une
nouvelle fois ville et campagne et qui
sont responsables de la désespérance
qu'on a en ce moment dans nos
territoires ruraux je vais le faire
observer que ici même en côte d'or là où
sam en charge de responsabilités
je veux remercier alain suguenot et tous
mes amis qui sont ici nous sommes arrivé
très largement en tête
le front national très largement
derrière ça montre bien que la meilleure
réponse finalement à cette montée de
l'extrême droite
la meilleure réponse c'est d'action de
demain nous allons nous remettre au
travail ensemble au service de la côte
d'or je participe aux travaux du conseil
régional je lui dis je démissionnerais
mon mandat parlementaire je les annonces
et je respecterai mes engagements je
veux dire à tous ceux qui nous ont fait
confiance que nous continuerons de nous
battre pendant ces six années au service
d'une belle et grande idée c'est que
nous voulons que ça change
nous voulons continuer d'investir
travailler pour nos jeunes parce que
c'est de cela qu'il s'agit
par delà le mouvement qui se passe
aujourd'hui c'est pour six ans que le
destin de la bourgogne franche comté est
engagé donc merci aussi aux habitants
d'ito qui m'ont placé en tête à 50% à
ceux de ma circonscription si très
largement en tête dans que merci à vous
tous en tout cas ne regrettait rien il
ya ceux qui se sont mis aux abris la
république et qui n'ont pas voulu
débattre après le terrible attentat que
nous avons connu le vendredi 13 de 27
partis socialistes sont mises
je répète aux abris de la république et
puis il ya ceux qui ont aussi de surfer
sur les peurs je crois que c'est dans
l'un comme dans l'autre cas ce ne sera
pas pour demain
la bonne réponse à tous ceux qui
engagent des débats sur la ligne sur les
lignes politiques qui auraient été
conduites je vous invite à bien
réfléchir juste pour ma part je suis
convaincu qu'il n'y a que des chemins de
traverse heures de l'union ordaz large
rassemblement et tous ceux qui parlent
de repartir sur la droite de change il
vit
ils oublient une seule chose c'est que
nous avons à répondre aux préoccupations
des français
de la vie quotidienne et c'est à ça que
je dois m'employer dès demain matin avec
tous mes amis
merci à tous vous avez fait une belle
campagne je crois qu'on peut dire de ce
que nous avons fait même si nouvelle que
ça sera d'être depuis son qg dijonnais
françois sauvadet qui dans quelle
annonce bien démissionner de son mandat
de parlementaire de députés et il
l'évoquait les trois départements qui
ont placé le front national en tête donc
en bourgogne franche comté le territoire
de belfort l'yonne et la haute saône
dans les autres départements marie-guite
dufay pour le ps est en tête et on
attend les résultats de la côte-d'or
donc il pourrait toutefois se rappeler
françois gilles platret une réaction
peut être à ce que vient de dire votre
tête de liste régionale notamment sur la
ligne politique de la droite à la
rejoignant dés ne n'était pas tout à
fait sur la même ligne déjà tout à
l'heure par téléphone
quelle est votre position à vous on a au
sein des républicains et françois
sauvadet parle évidemment au titre de
l'udps est ici on veut vraiment parler
sur le plan national
une démarche à conduire qui va être
conduite d'ailleurs dès cette semaine
savoir si nous devons infléchir ou pas
un certain nombre dax de réflexion
pourquoi est ce qu on le fait parce
qu'il ya un message il faut quelques
secondes tenir compte du contexte
national
aujourd'hui un pouvoir parti qui est au
pouvoir depuis des années des années
dans nos régions mais aussi sur
nationale n'arrive plus à rassembler
autour de lui et eux et il laisse
grandir à la je voyagerai l'a très bien
dit une force brutale qui est celle du
front national qui n'est pas une force
républicaine
même si monsieur noirot essaye de nous
chercher des poux dans la tête ça n'est
pas une force républicaine
c'était lé seigneur et monsieur noir ou
lait serait donc venir je ne sais pas si
c'est ça je vais finir mon propos je dis
simplement que nous ne pouvons pas nous
résoudre à voir d'un côté des français
qui critiquent la mer dans le
gouvernement pour les politiques qu'il
conduit et de l'autre des français qui
se jette dans les bras d'un parti qui
veut porter atteinte aux valeurs
fondamentales de la république française
cooper
ati mais c'est bien là que le débat doit
s'engager si nous sommes demain en
responsabilité parce que là la grande
bataille qui arriveront la connaît c'est
2010 est désormais les régionales sont
derrière nous les résultats sont en
train de s'affiner dans les dernières
régions françaises où nous ne savons pas
encore nous allons avoir une france qui
a rejeté front national dans toutes les
régions il faut bien le dire
donc quand on me dit c'est c'est nous
qui avons la majorité du peuple quand on
a la majorité du peuple on gouverne
visiblement c'est pas encore le front
national a perdu dans l'ensemble des
régions françaises
la gauche se sauve dans un contexte
particulier dans un certain nombre de
régions cinq ou six on verra exactement
fonction des résultats
donc il doit il est très clair
aujourd'hui que il y à une aspiration ou
renouvellement à l'alternance dans ces
mêmes dans les régions de france et
cette alternance elle est portée par qui
par une alliance entre les républicains
et lui dit
donc oui nous devons porter ce débat sur
la ligne je pense qu'avec alain joyandet
nous avons d'ailleurs c'est des sujets
de préoccupation commun et nous les
portons merci besoin au sein des
républiques écologie les verts de la
porte et en tongs nous partons pour
besançon on retrouve eric alauzet député
du doubs eric alauzet bonsoir une
réaction justement est-ce que même
question que pour christophe films nuits
du parti communiste est ce que pour vous
justement les verts ont réellement
contribué à cette victoire de la liste
de marie-guite dufay ce soir est-ce que
vous en êtes fier
les verts ont été totalement engagé dans
la deuxième semaine de campagne
électorale pour le deuxième tour et je
suis vraiment très heureux de la
victoire de marie-guite dufay tout en
regrettant bien entendu qu' il n'y ait
pas de représentants d'europe écologie
les verts dans la future majorité mais
c'est vraiment une grande satisfaction
et un soulagement
il faut aussi le reconnaître parce que
c'était très serré est ce que vous
regrettez que les verts n'y soit pas
allé dès le premier tour avec le parti
socialiste
alors même que les verts participer aux
exécutifs dans les deux régions
c'est dit c'est difficile à dire ce que
je peux vous dire quand même c'est que
non c'est vrai que le parti au
gouvernement et pas en odeur de sainteté
et qu'il est très critiquée parti
socialiste le gouvernement mais en même
temps tous ceux qui critiquent matin
midi et soir
y compris ses alliés de gauche comme les
verts ou le front de gauche et même à
droite qui critiquent matin midi et soir
je crois que le conte situation lassé de
ces querelles permanentes
ils savent ne constituent elles savent
que c'est très difficile de résoudre des
problèmes on a des problèmes économiques
financiers migratoire de climat et tous
ces problèmes sont mondiaux ils sont
internationaux
on pourrait mettre la meilleure personne
du monde président de la république seul
il n'y arriverait pas et donc les
français sont conscients de ça ils ne
supportent pas je supporte plus ces
querelles permanentes et puis l'autre
côté vous avez l'autre partie des
français qui eux
je suis désolé de dire se met à raconter
n'importe quoi matin midi et soir sur
les réseaux sociaux on lit vraiment des
énormités des bêtises qui contribuent à
nourrir le ressentiment le rejet de la
classe politique qui peut avoir par
ailleurs des raisons de s'en vouloir et
qui doit être sans reproche et en même
temps il ya beaucoup de choses qui sont
totalement exagéré donc je pense que six
manière générale il faut qu'on retrouve
un peu plus de tranquillité
un peu plus de réalisme dans notre
analyse de la situation est un peu plus
de bienveillance les uns vis-à-vis des
autres
ce n'est sans doute pas faux mais
justement est ce que votre parti pour
revenir à votre parti europe
ecologie-les verts dans ce contexte là
ne s'est pas finalement suicidé en
partant tout seul au premier tour et en
réalisant en bourgogne franche comté son
plus mauvais score
au niveau national mais si vous voulez
dire qu'on n'a plus d'élus effectivement
n'a plus d'élus au niveau régional ne
sais pas si c'est un suicide c'était un
choix bon moi j'ai un peu hésité à
l'époque traditionnellement vous savez
dans toutes ces élections à deux tours
que ce soit aux municipales aux
européennes ou régionales il ya souvent
eu plusieurs listes et c'était une façon
aussi d'aller parler de façon différente
à l'ensemble de la population et se
rassembler au second tour pour gagner
or le contexte a radicalement changé on
l'a vu avec la montée de l'extrémisme et
de la critique systématique des partis
traditionnels et on en a payé les pots
cassés voilà c'est difficile de vous
dire a posteriori je sais plus où même
facile de dire que c'est une erreur sur
le coup il ya un nom c'était plus
compliqué de prendre la décision
toujours est il que aux français on
essaiera de faire germer l'écologie au
sein de la nouvelle majorité régionale
député de la politique nationale faut-il
infléchir la politique du gouvernement
et tirer des leçons des résultats de ce
soir
ce que je vous disais précédemment sur
le fait que la critique de la droite
républicaine qui est nationalement ne
tire pas profit du rejet du gouvernement
c'est la première fois que je vois ça de
ne jamais vu ça que la critique à
l'intérieur de la gauche ne fait pas non
plus un bon score électoral
ça doit amener chacun à se poser des
questions c'est à dire que le
gouvernement doit effectivement et la
majorité doit se poser des questions
mais il faut aussi que les partenaires
du parti socialiste se pose également
les questions personne n'a raison et on
peut pas faire croire aux gens que comme
ça il y aurait une politique qui
sortirait du chapeau et qui réglerait
tout le problème
et quand certains disent faut changer de
cap le problème c'est que tout le monde
n'a pas le même cap même dans ceux qui
disent qu'il faut changer de cap
certains partira d'un côté et d'autres
d'autres donc un peu d'humilité de
réflexion et surtout arrêtons les
querelles inutiles pour aller vraiment
au coeur des sujets eric alauzet député
vert du djoon direct de besançon nous
avons entendu marie-guite dufay françois
sauvadet la parole maintenant à la tête
de liste du front national sophie montel
elf exprimé tout à l'heure depuis son
fief du jura 2 puis rend dans le jura
écouter ce soir on assiste heures
très objectivement à une victoire à la
pyrrhus de la part du d'un système que
nous dénonçons le système ump s madame
buffet visiblement l'emporterait d'une
très courte tête par rapport à mai sur
sauvadet le front national étant lui
aussi ça se joue dans un mouchoir de
poche
nous avons eu à faire effectivement nous
sommes arrivé très largement en tête au
soir du premier tour la semaine dernière
mais nous avons eu dans cet entre deux
tours à faire à une véritable campagne
de haine à l'encontre du front national
avec un premier ministre
particulièrement hystérique qui
préfèrent combattre le front national
plutôt que de résoudre le problème du
fondamentalisme islamiste en france ou
de réduire tout simplement la courbe du
chômage et d'infléchir les chiffres du
chômage
voilà des propos auxquels peuvent réagir
les invités qui se retrouve aux côtés de
catherine m mesurée à besançon qu'avec
elle michèle quellard et barbara
romagnan oui tout à fait j'ai avec côté
donc deux députés de franche-comté
barbara romagnan député socialiste du
doubs il fait partie de ce qu'on appelle
les frondeurs à l'assemblée nationale et
face à l michel keller député-maire de
valdoie dans le territoire de belfort
c'est le numéro 3 de l'udps et au niveau
national il y avait trois têtes de liste
udi en france les trois ce soir ont
perdu est ce que vous pouvez dire si les
républicains ont bien joué le jeu avec
vous ou pas oui je pense qu'on avait une
alliance qu'on assume et qu'ils ont
assumé donc là dessus il ya pas de
soucis on a aussi pris toute notre part
dans la victoire de xavier bertrand qui
je le rappelle toute cette semaine il
soutient même de jean louis borloo ce
qui est apparu ce qui n'est pas peu dire
valérie pécresse aussi avec chantal
rouleau on a pris tout ne peut pas il se
trouve qu'effectivement c'est une
déception parce qu'on souhaitait gérer
avec des têtes de l'utiliser ne s'est
pas trouvée mais alors pour le
changement de ligne on entend par
exemple anna joyan des cas l'air de dire
la société française se droitise donc il
faut qu'on la suive
vous vous dites quoi ce soir alors c'est
pas notre point de vue on le sait très
bien au contraire on pense que courir
derrière les thèses du front national ne
fera que faire grandir le front national
la seule donc votre cdi a du plomb dans
l aile ou a partout chacun doit amener
sa place à part et notre part à nous
les deux dévoile à nous avons des
valeurs centristes c'est toujours un peu
réducteur social démocrate il faut les
amener dans cette union c'est ça chacun
mais ne savent pas c'est pas pour ça que
les tests de sécurité doivent être
abandonnées ça veut dire que chacun de
trouver sa part mais par contre continue
de penser que courir derrière les thèses
du front national c'est une erreur même
si on n'a pas abandonné sujet que défend
le front national barbara romagnan donc
comme je disais tout à l'heure vous vous
êtes fondeuse vous prenez souvent
position contre le gouvernement et
l'assemblée nationale socialiste
pardon notamment parce que je suis
socialiste est-ce que ce soir donc
manuel valls a dit pas de triomphalisme
des remises en cause est ce que vous
êtes aussi sur cette ligne est-ce que
vous pensez que votre positionnement
politique
ces derniers mois en fait ne paraît pas
un peu décalé face et aux attentats et à
la menace du front national alors je
savais pas que c'était le sujet mais en
tout cas moi j'ai l'impression de
défendre les positions qu'on avait porté
jusque là pendant la campagne
présidentielle
il me semble que et marie-guite dufay
l'a déjà beaucoup dit point elle est
soulagée nous aussi on est soulagés
qu'elle l'ait emporté qu'on ait pu
l'emporter tous ensemble mais ce qui est
quand même le plus visible c'est que
l'abstention continue à être extrêmement
forte
la plus importante est que le front
national à un tiers des voix donc ça
veut dire je crois que nous il faut
qu'on revienne sur nos valeurs et qu'on
respecte les engagements qu'on prend ce
qu'on arrête de souci le gouvernement
était vraiment plus à gauche le front
national seraient plus bas moi je pense
que si le gouvernement respectait les
engagements que nous avons pris devant
les français
déjà ça participerait de d'une plus
grande confiance dans la politique
ensuite je pense que assez largement
aujourd'hui où on sert la soupe au front
national en parlant de déchéance de
nationalité on ne respectant pas notre
engagement sur la question du droit de
vote des étrangers notamment et surtout
qu'on doit se ressaisir de la question
sociale penser gros nez ce moment le
droit de vote des étrangers c'est le
moment mais je ne dis pas que c'est
aujourd'hui que c'est le moment mais
c'est un engagement que nous avons pris
c'est un renoncement de plus je crois
surtout que la gauche est là et le parti
socialiste en particulier
c'est notre mission historique et c'est
l'engagement que nous avons pris devant
les citoyens c'est de reprendre de la
question sociale
les inégalités sont extrêmement fortes
qu'est ce qu'on fait en matière de
retraite qu'est ce qu'on fait en matière
de salaires qu'est ce qu'on fait en
matière de chômage s'il ya des gens qui
votent front national s'est pas d'abord
contre des étrangers c'est d'abord parce
que le taux de chômage extrêmement élevé
on voit une correspondante extrêmement
forte entre le taux de chômage est le
vote front national en france donc je
pense que c'est ça la priorité
et puis qu'il faut qu'on soit capable de
mais tous ensemble de reconstruire d'une
ou de discuter de ce qu'on a en commun
comment faire en sorte que chacun puisse
être loger correctement si ça pour vous
d'opa triomphalisme et une véritable
remise en cause en profondeur
ce sac vous dites ce soit évidemment pas
de triomphalisme et je crois être un peu
conséquente avec ce que j'ai dit jusque
là et depuis que je suis élu je ne suis
pas je suis depuis 22 ans parti
socialiste je ne suis pas un gauchiste
je continue à défendre les options que
nous avions défendu quand on s'est
présenté dans les gens ce pas simplement
une question ligne c'est une question de
démocratie
et vous michel kreder 2017 18 mois avant
ce nouveau scrutin vous voyez ça comment
par rapport justement un front national
on le disait donc droit être gauche pro
nationale chacun un tiers de l'électorat
qu'est-ce qu'il va falloir faire il ya
un point qui peut nous rassembler c'est
à dire nos concitoyens ont des questions
des interrogations
donc à nous de répondre à leurs
questions leurs interrogations on va pas
continuer à résoudre à affronter le
seulement le front national les soirs
d'élection effectivement nos concitoyens
ont des problèmes de chômage de sécurité
par l'ong leurs problèmes et si on
trouvait des solutions on résoudra la
situation et ans permettra que les
élections qui se déroulent dans
maintenant un an et demi va permettre à
un républicain au sens large évidemment
de gagner parce que c'est ça qui est
important
mais je crois qu'on peut y arriver mais
par contre il pas la politique
politicienne la politique et apporte des
réponses à ceux qui ont sont dans la
difficulté
marmara romagnan dernière question
malgré tout ce que vous voulez un
positionnement plus à gauche
magritte où on voit que ceux qui sont à
la gauche du parti socialiste au premier
tour dimanche dernier n'ont pas réussi à
ramener énormément des lecteurs sur
leurs noms mais ça ça concerne tout le
monde sage j'en suis bien d'accord et
moi je ne dis pas simplement une pas
plus à gauche je dis qu'on prend des
engagements qu'il s'agit de les
respecter puisque on est en démocratie
et je crois que les défis qui sont
devant nous aujourd'hui à la fois la
question la question climatique la
question des inégalités pour l'instant
il est manifeste qu'on les a pas résolu
donc ça fait trois ans et demi qu'on est
au pouvoir on a une responsabilité
particulière et constater qu'on n'a pas
les résultats qu'on veut quand par
ailleurs on a pris des engagements et
qu'on ne les respectent pas oui je crois
que ça doit amener à une certaine remise
en cause abba peut-être donc des prêts
four pour faire réagir sur le plateau à
dijon si vous avez encore un peu de
temps merci beaucoup on va merci
beaucoup
catherine en va tout d'abord donner les
toutes dernières estimations des
résultats avec donc des résultats
définitifs 34,7 % pour la liste
socialiste marie-guite dufay 30 2,9 pour
cent pour la liste de françois sauvadet
lr udi qui arrive donc en deuxième
position juste devant donc le front
national 32,1 à 4 % pour le front
national
l'écart se creuse s'est donc creusé une
chaîne audio c'est une satisfaction
j'imagine la majorité c'est un tout
petit peu plus confortable oui mais vous
savez c'est pas le demi point qui compte
on se satisfait effectivement je lui ai
dit tout à l'heure de cette victoire
matin il faut regarder devant il faut
construire il faut faire en sorte que
nos politiques répondent aux attentes et
moi je crois que par rapport à tout ce
qui a été dit il ya quand même une
coupure du vote entre le monde des
villes et le monde rural qui se sent
oublié on shore d' en bourgogne et en
franche comté de négociations
contractuelles
oui j'étais partie parce que vous allez
on va juste cet article sur la
répartition des sièges avant rappelle
les derniers chiffres disponibles 34 7%
des voix pour marie-guite dufay donc
résultats définitifs pour la bourgogne
franche comté qui donnerait 51 sièges
pour la liste de gauche françois
sauvadet l'érudit 32,9 25 sièges et le
front national avec sophie montel 32,4
obtiendrait 24 sièges des chiffres que
nous venons d'avoir et que nous
commencerons dans un quart d'heure de la
suite de cette émission spéciale
bourgogne franche comté tout de suite
carole gaessler et francis letellier a
tout de suite